hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John old Humphrey you're not gonna
do your intro and I'm sure I really did
come up with that off the top of my head
the first hey guys we're gonna talk
about Rocket Man the biopic musical
biopic based on the life of Elton John
now this whole life a very specific
chapter that revolves around of course
his rise to fame and this music industry
but ultimately all wrapped around this
through line of when he became a drug
addict when he became clean I'm just
awful saying this the movie has an
outline that is generally a very cliche
biopic it's the outline of the struggle
of abusive parents to the rise of fame
to getting into drugs and then having to
get clean what makes this movie freakin
incredible is the unique approach and
the unique execution to it it's not just
hey how'd they make that cool song you
know every time I thought this was just
gonna be a very cliche generic scene
there was always a different flip right
from the very beginning I don't want to
spoil it because there's other biopics
where you're like I don't want to spoil
people could just look this up because
it's a true story they've done some
unique approaches from from the get-go
where you think you're gonna watch a
generic biopic but it never goes down
that path and I want to immediately say
a Taron Egerton deserves an Oscar
nomination for this movie I have always
thought he's an amazing actor Eddie to
eagle you guys should really go check
that out yeah I do love I mean Kingsman
this dude has a lot of versatility and
he embodies Elton John in this movie he
has the benefit of being good friends
with the guy so he can absorb him like a
sponge yeah or a symbiote yes venom no I
totally agree I mean I had such a
wonderful time watching this movie and
it just has such a life about it there
are going to be certain aspects of any
biopic they're gonna be kind of similar
especially when we're dealing with the
music industry but yeah this movie
really sets itself apart in how create
léa it tells its story and how it
chooses to not only focus on the facts
and the literal elements of Elton John's
life but also the figurative aspects and
the nuances as well we saw those fantasy
elements in the trailer and that was for
a lot of people one of the most exciting
aspects of this and I think they really
use them in a way that completely
complements the central figures so yeah
I had a great time it's me this is kind
of like walk the line meets across the
universe because across the universe
uses the Beatles songs to tell a story
but heavily rearranged and kind of
restage yeah because I love the way they
executed the songs here it's not only
Taron Egerton be recording the songs in
terms of the vocal Department and it's
not just live performance scenarios no
what was unique about it was they used a
lot of his songs that he co-wrote with
Bernie Taupin Bernie tope and played by
Jamie Bell in this movie throughout the
film they break into musical numbers to
complement the storytelling there are
times in the same scene where a
different character very important to
Elton John in that moment would take
over the song take over the verse here
and they did it in a way where there was
a different kind of cadence a different
kind of delivery that way you're still
getting a scene out of it you're still
getting an emotional aspect you know and
walk the line when Johnny Cash is in the
recording booth and he's talking about
give me a song with real emotion it's
like that scene but throughout this
whole movie yeah and what's magical too
is that you're not just waiting for the
different moments where they're gonna
write a certain song or whatever in just
the actual circumstances of the music so
much of these songs were collaborations
between Elton John doing the music and
the melodies and Bernie Taupin writing
the lyrics in a celebration of not only
the man's life but his music as well I
thought it was really interesting the
way that you get to apply the music yeah
to different times in his life and not
just see him performing what you do
there are some great recreations of some
famous shows but it really brought out
the life in the lyrics in a whole other
way and you had to have them staged with
multiple singers and different
arrangements and certain moments that
are even full-on musical numbers with
ensemble dancers yet tough I thought
that really added a whole new flavor
that again is just totally Elton
the way they had fantasy-like sequences
that really dive deep into the
psychology of Elton John I thought was
so different for this film and it never
got crazy you never got to weird
to the point where it's a little
off-putting I still feel like mainstream
audiences can definitely absorb this
movie so much credit really rests on the
directors hands Dexter Fletcher we know
his involvement that he had with
Bohemian Rhapsody this movie is all his
own and man does he do something so
different than I'm used to with biopics
I just can't help but admire it every
category that Bohemian Rhapsody was
nominated for this movie should
definitely hit nominate for all those
categories and Dexter Fletcher should
get a Best Director nomination I fully
think so I mean this movie to me just
played out so smoothly I was engrossed
and roused the entire time I felt all
the different emotions pretty naturally
there are a couple of moments that made
me genuinely touched and crying I cried
a couple of times there's a specific
sequence towards the end I don't want to
give away the way they handle a lot of
the style how'd you put it some things
are like figurative some things are kind
of literal yeah I feel like a lot of
biopics focus on the literal for the
most part and this one does have the
literal but it also goes really into the
figurative of different moments or
interludes in his life going back to
some of the visuals style cues I feel
like a lot of these movies get stylistic
when someone's strung out on drugs or
whatever and it's you are they gonna
make it through whatever situation but
this movie also does that for really
high elated moments to use that scene
where he's floating off the piano or
different moments on stage where they'll
have these visual elements that really
immerse you into a feeling moreso yet an
event you know yeah it wasn't one of
those movies where I was distracted by
is this true or not yeah because I was
so engrossed in the way they decided to
tell this story I do think that some
people might have a hard time getting on
board initially like for myself even
when when they first start off with
their first musical number I was like am
I gonna enjoy this after a while I
really did start to get into it because
you start from the childhood and know
whoever the child actors are of Elton
John's are really good too but when you
get to deterrant Edgerton wouldn't air
nitrogens playing Elton John that's when
it really started to click the movie
really started to engross
me heavily once you get to the Bernie
character played by Jamie Bell who I
think deserves a Supporting Actor
nomination
oh yeah their relationship is so much
the heart of this movie it's the part of
this movie and their chemistry and like
their first scene yeah their first scene
every time you think this is gonna be
another generic by-the-numbers
scene it doesn't devolve in today it
doesn't become that much they share a
moment and what's smart about that is
you see what endeared them to each other
not just that they became friends yes
you know and and you fall in love with
their relationship with each other and
and in a movie that has so much about
love and the lack of love and for a
person who at least by the facts of this
movie grew up in a pretty loveless
environment you really do come to hold
on to shouts out really quick don't
forget that thought Bryce Dallas Howard
Oh
is great man this could have been a
one-note performance of a person playing
like messed up mom to Elton John Bryce
house Howard is very layered in here and
a man is she great in this movie yeah I
didn't realize she was in it when she
showed up and she does just blend yes
right into her role but yeah like in a
movie that focuses so much on the
yearning for love and the lack of love
his relationship with Bernie does prove
to be the one through line that even
through the ups and downs it is the
longest-running most loving relationship
that the movie Alicia knows that he had
it's like it's like a brotherhood
dynamic truly the other thing I didn't
realize I was watch this movie's r-rated
count the amount of efforts I was
hearing at one point when I was like
this is movie crap Elton John had a lot
of struggles with his homosexuality this
movie does not shy away from it's a big
integral part to his journey they could
have probably gone more graphic if they
wanted to but for what a lot of these
movies do they didn't shy away from it's
a good thing and this movie does not shy
away from it the movie is basically
recounting a his life story and when
he's in rehab he does say he was a sex
addict and there's even this really cool
visual number it's like you don't see
him boning a bunch of dudes in the movie
but there's this cool visual number
that's implying a lot into the hyper
sexual orgy lifestyle
getting insanely graphic about it yeah
you really get the idea and they yeah
they don't need to be super frivolous
yes but there is a scene in here where
I'm like I'm so happy this movie exists
and sure they could they have given us
like an insanely graphic sexy and sure
it could have been Team America yeah
they wanted to but for most movies they
would definitely have pg-13 this [ __ ]
down and there's a scene in here where
I'm like man they really went for it and
I'm happy they did yeah for all you rob
stork yes yeah he's good in the movie
he's probably the most cliched like the
second sphere like okay what's gonna
happen talk the point you come into this
movie I'm like I know exactly who this
character is he's the most generic of
them all buddy he does do a good job I
guess the last thing I'll say is the way
this movie executes its themes this
movie breathes very well it's not in a
rush it's not like oh by the time you
get to act 2 he's super famous you know
yeah like there's a while you spend with
his childhood it's a while you spend
with the struggle in the journey before
he starts making some hits does it have
a little bit of that syndrome that
biopics tend to suffer with of like wait
how much time has passed exactly what
point what year we at now occasionally
it does slip into that however the movie
does breathe excellently and I think the
way they handled its somatic qualities
of a guy who is loved by millions but
doesn't feel like he'll ever be loved
individually and there's this other
theme in there too of you have to kill
who you were in order to become the
person you want to beat that's a very
established early on in the film and it
really lives in that space yeah
throughout as he gets more famous the
unresolved things from his past just
seemed to get stronger darker they seem
to get a bigger hold of him so this life
of Fame is this escapism but it's all
embedded in this trying to get away from
this pain from his past that just seems
to be consuming his life and I love the
way they handled that not just in a
psychological storytelling way but in a
visual palette there's a scene towards
the end that if you see the movie you'll
know what I'm talking about there's a
moment there just like man I started
really cry
and how thinking about its negative
again it's so power it's touching it's a
very very touching movie I'm not just
touching because it's Elton John I think
it's touching too because you'll relate
this movie is really thought out
wonderfully performed the musical
numbers are great the approach is
awesome the themes explored are
excellent this is one of the best
biopics I've seen in a very very long
time it's pretty obvious if I have to
compare this to believe me in Rhapsody
yeah of course I prefer this over it
it's different don't go in expecting
Bohemian Rhapsody
my concern is bohemian came out late in
the year so it was easier to get
acknowledged for Oscar nomination yeah
I'm really hoping this does not get
forgotten about because this is a
special film I'm not even a big Elton
John I'm not no Elton John song I'm not
like enthusiast but this was one of the
biopic that made me the way how Ray
affected me the way I walk the line
affected me me me go I want to hear more
Elton John now yeah yeah no I agree with
you 100% I mean I just got swept up in
this movie I had such a great time I
really reacted hard to this movie I
laughed a lot I cried I was really
invested in his journey and going with a
comparison to Bohemian Rhapsody it's
just this is the movie I wish that movie
could have been because it really does
complement its central figure and again
I don't know all the history I haven't
done a deep dive on this but where is
Bohemian Rhapsody to me felt kind of
disingenuous or like it was trying to
polish up the story this felt very just
genuine to me I feel like this is an
example of what good can come of
somebody having a hand in their own
biopic because he says it himself
I was an [ __ ] some of the time like I
did some really bad decisions and the
movie seems yet to present the story in
a way that is very relatable but feels
pretty real and yeah I can't compliment
the different departments enough yeah
they're definitely scenes where you're
like yeah yeah and I appreciate that it
didn't shy away from that I mean they
all this is so three-dimensional all
these movies get to that area but this
movie embraced it for me so yeah just I
love this movie for the most part yeah
go watch it guys go watch it
alright guys well have you seen Rock a
man did you love it would you do you
want to see a cinematic crossover with
Bohemian Rhapsody Rockstar cinematic
Bowie movie here too you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects if you
liked our review please hit the like
button last but not least I would see of
a page from the day shots a man named JN
Valente J and Valente this right here
your shout out is your song you make me
wanna fly like with Benny and the Jets
dude your no candle in the wind man can
you feel the love tonight and you feel
the love tonight you make me one I go to
the space like a rocket man JN yeah and
just crocodile rock out with our socks
oh yeah and I want you to pet my hunky
catch ya cuz it's the circle of life man
in it and it moves us all song for a guy
Saturday nights alright goodbye yellow
brick road
janitor you're assessing music water
song I love you buddy I hope we hope
with Chavez a message like a month ago
where the hell have you been
he'll pop back in three